let's bring you some news coming in from
China and state media is reporting that
the government has reappointed Wang Yi
as its foreign minister now that follows
um the they're also saying that they've
removed Chen Gunk from the post of
foreign minister he hasn't been seen in
public for a month and speculation over
his whereabouts was Rising let's bring
in our China correspondent for more on
this she's joining us by Skype from
Beijing so really interesting
announcement coming in as we've all been
wondering where Qin Gang has been
that's right today marks the fourth week
of qingdong not being seen in public the
last time it was seen was during a an
official meeting with the Vietnamese
foreign minister in Beijing at the end
of June and there's been a lot of
speculation as to his whereabouts for a
long time now mofa the foreign ministry
here has been dodging questions uh
saying that they don't have any
information the only hint of information
that we had about uh his absence from a
flurry of diplomatic activity was when
he failed to participate in the Asian
Foreign ministers meeting in Jakarta
earlier this month and they sent Wang Yi
the top Diplomat who is now the foreign
minister instead and they simply said
that he was absent for health reasons
um so this is extremely shocking he was
a very high level uh uh minister in the
Chinese Communist Party he was a state
councilor and also seen as a trusted
Ally and advisor for president Xi
Jinping
Katrina do we know do we have any idea
where Qin gang is and what do we make of
the state media announcing along with
Wang Yi being reappointed as foreign
minister they've announced another
appointment
um another change as well
that's why we had also announced was a
change in the Central Bank Governor um
but that was actually expected that was
already lined up that the really most
shocking headline uh is that qingang has
lost his position and the reason that's
shocking is that he was only uh
inaugurate or given that position last
December so it's a very very short time
and just a little bit about qingang his
rise was really seen as meteoric and
very rapid through the ranks of the
Communist Party it usually takes up to a
decade for somebody to reach his
position at the age of 57 he's seen as
one of the youngest officials to gain
the role as foreign minister but Heroes
relatively quickly in part analysts say
because of his closeness to president Xi
Jinping before he was appointed as
foreign minister he spent two years as
China's ambassador to the United States
and then was before that a foreign
Ministry spokesperson known for his wolf
Warrior or assertive style when it came
to Chinese diplomacy he was very much
seen in favor with the top top echelons
of the Chinese Communist party now as to
his whereabouts we have of course that
mentioned from China's foreign Ministry
about his health but there has been
other speculation on social media about
maybe inappropriate behavior but all of
this is also I must say unverified and
not backed up officially but it is
confirmed now four weeks out of public
view is because he fell foul of the
Communist Party authorities we do expect
hopefully over the next few days to get
a bit more of an uh explanation but this
Fortune gang is quite a spectacular haul
from grace for somebody who was seen
quite as quite favored and a bit of a
Communist Party Golden Boy up until his
mysterious uh disappearance last month
all right Katrina thank you very much
for that um that is Katrina you with the
latest from China on the Chinese State
media announcing that they're replacing
foreign minister qingang with foreign
with the former foreign minister